hey what's up my name is Ron Artest you
know I changed it to Metta World Peace
also changed it to the pandas friend if
you in China and this is the moment I
mean so the moment I knew I was gonna
change my name from Ron Artest
to Metta World Peace it was when Chad
Ochocinco changes me I felt real
inspired about it I thought it was dope
and I had all these different things I
had like Queensbridge I had so heard a
lot of street names that I wanted and
then as I evolved as a person and things
started to influence a life I started to
fall in love with the meditation Zen and
Indian culture and I see have medicating
from the biggest complication I ran into
when I changed my name was triple-a but
Triple A you have to go to triple-a she
will change your name there's no calling
them know nothing online
everything else was smooth my Triple A
still say Ron Artest to this day I don't
know where the Triple A office and New
York City people call me Ron sometimes
Chicago Indiana the LA some people call
me met up kids called me mr. world P
sometimes New York is is not calling any
metal you know I'm from New York I get
it I'd know we're from New York and it
is what it is the difference between Ron
Artest about the play I met about pieces
a 23 year old when our test was a
difficult player that play gets you know
Metta World Peace is pretty pretty easy
you can get over warning this is the
moment I knew